head today I me pick nothing no not even
any goomy's you got either after this
what you whine it goes [ __ ] he's four
or five oh yeah yeah okay what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna eat half this prick 40 you
know what you know I went to Joey's
store with Joey I'm not eating him buddy
no I'm not you're Joey
nothing will pop out I'm saying oh yeah
that is a little cup in your stuff guys
trip for beers on travel table to second
EF no rear episode if you don't need it
Leo have to leave lately I wanted one
and a half there's a club here what I
want like who walks around with a leg
and a half
nobody oh come on no I do there it is
ready good [ __ ] god
oh great time Las Vegas this weekend if
you came to the South Point the scene I
want to thank you for the that was an
easy weekend [ __ ] great time what I
was telling you was that 1983 I was
walking past a window one day I was
doing laundry on the Lord's Day minding
my own [ __ ] business
my mom just doing launching football was
on I wasn't in the mood I was living in
Snowmass Village and I was in Creekside
apartments and I'm walking I look at
this window as I'm walking by and the
windows open but there's a screen in
front of it but the door is right there
yeah all I have to do stick my hand rip
the screen I'll stick my hand I got this
[ __ ] fools paradise
I knew the guy saw him early up at the
[ __ ] bar up at the Mexican place and
I knew there was some type of drugs in
his house yeah I stuck my hand in there
went in I got a chunk of hash I got some
jewelry
I got like 1500 the rubber band and I
got a like a couple grams of blow you
know loose blown gram here take an old
lady's blow
miscellaneous blowing ice put it
together and I ran out in
home and I buried the 15 grand and I
took the jury and I put in one little
safe my bunny was a property manager
those days for some property management
company and I went to condos that were
under construction and I would put all
the stolen loot in the same sweater we'd
have the combination that's gonna where
I got away with all that [ __ ] so they
came to my house there was none of my
house the blow I kept that was going
down and the hash I had a little spot
under the closet where I ripped up the
carpet and with a knife I picked up the
wood it was like my little I always
since I was a kid I was always one of
those creepy dudes that wanted to be
James Bond yeah yeah I love pic hiding
fiberboard yeah I love picking up
floorboards and digging it out I love
all that crazy [ __ ] to me that was the
easiest heist of my life December 18
1983 I might called my buddy to say hey
I'm sending you a package tomorrow look
out for a chunk of hash some jewelry
move the jewelry and we'll split it 5050
it was like a jewelry yeah honor he goes
it's my birthday okay and I made a
mental notes and I read this underrated
paper I call him on his birthday because
of that robbery my point my point is
Vegas was easier
that's how much of a good time I had in
Vegas what did you say you bury the
thing do you like bury it in the ground
you buried money no there was a closet
that people in the building could put
their skis and [ __ ] uh and you had to
have a couple keys for it and then went
in there and I [ __ ] dug something out
in the corner you couldn't see it unless
you're a professional there was no way
you can see it and I put it in there
that's why I kept the 15 grand so I went
back to Jersey in 84 now is this about
the same time you went to Miami oh we
were talking about my ass yeah for I was
talking about you know like you've given
this illusion when you're 19 20 that
there's stuff going on there's always
stuff going on you know oh my god it
sucks here yeah I heard that where's the
party at
the party's in Texas my friend went he
said that he made out with eight chicks
and they got six [ __ ] and chicks
with topless and your head almost
explodes and that's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
story you know but in your mind then you
see the Budweiser commercials
they're partying and well it wasn't as
crazy I like the commercials and I was
the craziest commercials were Rodney you
know remember those commercials from
Miller Lite those are [ __ ] classic
but it wasn't you had this illusion that
you were going to go out so I grew up in
New York City so when I was like 20 my
friend said hey man my buddy's a part
time in studio 54 my head almost
exploded he was I'll get you in come out
I go let's go you know it was like 80
[ __ ] - the party was over then but -
just go in there and I went in there
expecting to see like people give him
[ __ ] no it wasn't like that it was
just people being free so my friend said
to me at one point you want to get high
yeah let's go into the woman's bathroom
and you were a man and here you weren't
in the woman's bathroom because it was
like the main room you ever go to back
in the main room they have that
accommodation they have those boots with
mirrors with those big bulbs around them
in studio 54 they had 50 of those in a
row really so people would go in there
with that cocktail smoke and do coke
where the women are supposed to be by
makeup on they weren't actually in the
back of the woman we're pissing they
would sit there
you follow me yeah when you went to
tables people were doing blow but I
would say like three times and I thought
that that was it that was the perfect
[ __ ] Club even though I didn't get my
dick sucked even don't nobody talk to me
I didn't get one woman to talk to me I
didn't dance with anybody like that was
the utopia you know that was it but I
always thought like oh my god I'm going
to Colorado with the Colorado that was
the worst night life in the [ __ ]
world really and I gotta tell you
something I went to all these cities
like compared to what I grew up with
nothing is [ __ ] I never seen anything
you know I don't want to go see if I can
cover banner in the bar
I'm too old guy I'm not gonna sit there
and listen to brown sugar that's not
happening in my [ __ ] world but there
was one place I went in 1984 that was
crazy and it was Coconut Grove Florida
with the Improv is today it's gone then
cocaine was huge and sorry
that place was something I had never
seen before
really I went to visit my family and my
cousin said we're going out we went like
the pink parrot one of those and that
was why saw
[ __ ] if 400 people in there everybody
was on blood like everybody was on blow
everybody wants to be on Miami Vice it
was right a small way to be about me
this le dress like it and [ __ ] racin
brother in between Scarface and Miami
Vice yeah you have no idea what was
happening really you just have no idea I
was in Florida I remember I remember I
don't remember Scarface coming out but I
do remember my advice I remember like
Ron Bennington was a big I'm B was a big
deal around that time in Florida
Ron baby Ronnie B was in it was DJ of
Tampa who's Ron Bennington he does a run
in Fez radio show okay
yeah she's tremendous you'd live he
always Joey you do love love I know them
yeah yeah where are they now
they're New York Ron's and Ron bangtan's
New York Ron Perez is I think in Tampa
Miami can you turn the bass down in my
voice sounds a little tinny bring that
beat back but uh yeah Ronnie be like
those big cigarette boats and yeah yeah
cut off shirts like Hulk Hogan used to
wear Florida's maniacs dude it's a crazy
state really crazy it's a really crazy
state and it's one like it's like Nevada
in the sense that like if you [ __ ] off
want to be like [ __ ] off Society I'm
kind of like I do [ __ ] on I bend a lot
of rules I'm kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like it's a great state to thrive in you
know like there's so many the most
scumbags I've ever met in my life was
living in Florida
really yeah for sure so many [ __ ]
scumbags a lot of racists a lot of races
yeah not everything
yeah a lot every there's not everything
the biggest it's a big private or I
would state it's it's been [ __ ]
getting mauled on since God knows when
yeah you know you know Columbus was down
and I mean it's just I think Jesus was
down there everybody's been down it no
state income tax John Leeson was down
there it's just one of those places and
for me and I'm not saying this in a
negative way anything above like West
Palm Beach I don't click to me it's very
yeah it's very more little it's in
between Sun and something else yeah that
went to Jackson building dig me I got
went to that Mandarin then at one time
that's there all the seafood you could
eat Friday night
good old boy left oh yeah Oh Cal I've
never really been Benton that's not your
world
Tampere live oak I don't do good in
Tampa you know it really I would think a
lot of Cubans in Tampa great [ __ ]
city great food just sensational yeah
just a great blend of food a lot of New
Yorkers with flavor a lot of Cuban food
a lot of Latin [ __ ] good
cheeseburgers but I think like the only
city I'm gonna tell you something guys
there's only been two cities in my life
where I was I died I came close to diet
where's that one is Florida Miami yeah
and the other one I think is Houston
Texas one that's a pretty sets of Savas
real well the [ __ ] City yeah yes in
Texas before after the hurricane okay
it's after Katrina Houston got real
[ __ ] wild yeah I got crazy it got
real Christmas Katrina 2005 I think that
no yes it's 2003 2002 I was going crazy
on my own death yeah yeah I was a great
club that that laughs see I used to love
the last time I went there after
governor well I gotta know what they're
after man would be Hauser Pete was great
guy I love to be Pete had his little
[ __ ] prong
I love BP just came to see me in Houston
losers yeah I'm still tight would be how
[ __ ] up he wants every 16 days by the
way Danny Murphy whoo yeah Dan Murdock
died old Tempe improv old 10:00 p.m. you
what a fine shame yeah yeah how'd he die
you know I've been wrong nobody's said
Tom and you know where Chicago is
inaudible year and a half ago for a
reference
trying to get a manager's job at the
Chicago laugh actory that's the last I
said he was living with his brother he
took the money the club game they robbed
him he lost condo Bachmann
it was like [ __ ] a tizzy it was like
a he [ __ ] did a lot of creepy things
down there man God rest in peace you
know he was good snake things it wasn't
good
yeah he was a creepy [ __ ] brother I
never get told his hair was his real dog
don't you ever you ever got a few know
and the guys talking like they give a
memorial in the back here like this is
such a [ __ ] last time I swear I was
doing blow yeah hell first rip his ankle
and this kid he's a loving father sure
he's gonna see them that night but you
love the skins when the others hung up
that [ __ ] yawns [ __ ] [ __ ] with
coke Garland's all those loving father's
they always are the dirtiest
[ __ ] in the world dirtiest
[ __ ] normal I went to the
tempie and prop one time and Gary
Valentine and uh then a bunch of comics
told me you got a party with Dan with
Dan Murr I was like okay so I get there
I was when we used to tour with what's
Navin yeah we get there and we sit down
and I say to Dan I'm not drinking
tonight but I want to get down on a
party with you and he's like yeah he's I
was like Gary and Kevin James all these
guys said you're really fun to party
with you so or it'll happen I was like
yeah it's like Friday night Thursday
night Friday night he's like I'm not
gonna be able to do it tonight we'll do
it hit it tomorrow night so Saturday
comes I'm kind of like I don't thought I
don't want to party with him but I just
don't really care easy I just said what
I was supposed to say to be cool
Saturday night come to me and I dodge
out on it and he uh he'd I don't see him
I leave I'm like thank God I got to do
one Sunday Sean I'm just gonna drive
home Sunday night he corners me at the
green room oh yeah
he's like that's not nice tonight's your
night bro and I was like okay so I was
like all right so I've put all my [ __ ]
back in the condo parked the car and I
was like I'm going out partying with Dan
and we just went to that shooters right
down the street
uh-huh just went there and he's just sat
down at the bar and he just looked at me
go so what do you think I was like what
he's like this is it man this is like
you're partying with me and I was like
[ __ ] why yeah who's weird how long did
you guys hear really [ __ ] up or now
yeah no we just had enough drinks where
we couldn't drive back to LA and then he
was just call it a night and I was like
oh [ __ ] so I did was that was the last
time I really he was he is interesting
to me how many people you put all
your eggs in that basket sometimes in
this business with like a club owner or
manager and you're like alright I got
this place and you just cool [ __ ] and
also one day they're gone and you're
like I got line drunk with what's the
the old the guy that was running Houston
improv the big heel out that okay no not
not a tray non hippie guy never guy yeah
yeah is a KP so creepy guys dad the
other guy no no he's a creepy [ __ ] they
they set them to Arlington he's the
rapist he's a trauma I was saying yeah
they put him they put him in row they
put him in Arlington you know Dan Mayer
was a [ __ ] dirty coach like the like
the filthy coke cream and they he would
get so coked up that you think he had a
stroke his liquid turn like his lip was
just awkward so one night everybody for
years one night when I had two really
bad sleep apnea and I really wasn't
sleeping I didn't know what I didn't
know what god I know what the sleep
apnea with the effects were yet uh-huh I
passed out one night really hard knocks
and I wake up to the door banging and
it's Joe Rogan pre marijuana when he was
[ __ ] miserable I always say he was an
ape you ever see the evolution of a Nana
that's when he was an 8 yeah he didn't
no joke no matter what it wasn't it
wasn't it was like spur --tz-- there was
something missing
thank God had he talked him into that
because you didn't know why he was
anti-drug yeah anti [ __ ] drug you know
if it Burt came over and the next day
he'd call me no Bert Kreischer had like
16 [ __ ] beers he's got a background
you know and he would just say that I
remember we went to see Doug Stanhope
that's how it started he's like [ __ ]
Doug is funny but somebody's gotta talk
to him about his alcohol is on my Joe
nobody says things like that like nobody
I go why would you say that goes why
would I say that
he had 11 beers and four shots of
tequila on States
that's how uptight Joe Rogan used to be
cuz I don't even recognize that God no
no he gave me Ricky Cruz and Ralphie may
[ __ ] for smoking pot to calm me slowing
oh really that's that's how twisted he
was then anti he was very by-the-book
you know what's his name it just died
from drugs who uh the guy I'm saying
that's live his buddy on a news radio
and all that Oklahoma's very he got shot
though right something there's home with
Joe that he was very and he would not
discuss cocaine with me at that time
like he wouldn't tell like I wouldn't
ever ever be high in front of him and
one night we all said goodnight and I
went back to my room and I started
watching TV and I just passed out guys
and I had a bone bone bone bone that's
Joe Rogan with the Security shall we
open up the door you all right what the
[ __ ] we were supposed to be downstairs
at 8:30 now we missed our [ __ ] flight
and all this [ __ ] on my hold on he's
looking around my room and I'm like no
dawg
I was to bed last night and the whole
way there him and Chris Maguire yakking
like I know he was a dead man Chris
Maguire I don't the bald that's when
when we use Chris Maguire me used to
open for job I remember Chris McLaren
EMS ahead right brother
yeah the ruse all those roasts and we
get to the [ __ ] Airport and the
flights delayed for hours
so all that yelling and screaming was
for no [ __ ] reason I even told him I
go see the flights [ __ ] delayed who
gives a [ __ ] but he always thought I was
a Danny Murr and I'll tell you guys
right now I never did a line of blow
with Danny Murr this is what I did not
add anymore when that I knew what Danny
more did and Danny more knew what I did
okay there's people that you have
relationships like that that like let's
say Lee's a coke dealer yeah Lee knows
that Lee knows that you and Berta
friends I know that Bert goes to Lee and
Bert knows that I go to we we just don't
say it to one another but there's times
that we'll be talking out even though me
and burn on her friends I'll see Bert
and I go you see Lita ago no no I saw
him last night so it's our little secret
but write the books yeah as I'm saying
yeah
so I always knew that he got and he knew
I got we never really did anything but
one night he calls me up and he goes hey
man I got two tickets for the stones at
the Hollywood ball he was you want to go
I'm 400 [ __ ] pounds I'm smoke
two packs three packs of Camel Lights a
day and I'm doing a gram and a half a
blow at this time he's this great I'm
living on Schrader I'm a [ __ ] mess
yeah externally internally so I meet him
a no compadre and I buy two four 20s
about no my kid like 10 20s cuz I know
him and I know me and when he gave him
my ticket I shook his hand and I put
three 20s in his hand and he took him to
put in this pocket he never told me
thank you that's old school
yeah listen you don't know no no no no
that's the only drug exchange that
happened he bought he paid a limo
we took a limo from el compadre to the
[ __ ] thing we got out of that car my
heart my fat little hearts beating from
the blow and the cigarettes you ever
walk up that Hollywood Bowl you ever
want to rip the tickets up and punch the
person in the face who had the ideas to
go there yes but it's all or it's all go
from island and frankly oh my god by the
time you get to the top you want to
shoot yourself yeah so we walk in the
seats were just I could see the sweat on
Mick Jagger you know Danny murdered in
[ __ ] around
yeah that's one thing that dude swung
hard he had tickets from [ __ ] you
know Letterman's assistant but that's
who got him those tickets like somebody
bigs assistant you could see Mick
Jagger's sweat but the problem was the
coke made me want to smoke cigarettes in
those days he couldn't smoke in there I
couldn't smoke in this one after one one
time I went up there by the time I got
up I was huffed and puffed Thomas and
all I smoke three cigarettes my blood
pressure is 200 I went right back down
after three or four more songs I do
another couple blasts I walk back up to
the top again three cigarettes I walk
back down
finally I'm down and I go [ __ ] now I got
a pee I walk all the way back up there I
be and I go you know what I'm not
walking back down and I just left I
walked right to my apartment got the
[ __ ] rest of that 8 ball and blast
off he kept calling me way you had [ __ ]
he won't even answer the phone I think I
had a pager back then I started to paint
yeah [ __ ] you have to be ran to the
phone
he's got to be a heart attack right fat
Dammers heart I don't know he died of a
broken heart bro some people die of
broken hearts last time I talked to him
there's got to be hard to take that
tumble because it from going to run in
one of the more popular clubs in the
country where everyone wants to work to
getting run out I guess Mark Anderson
killed himself and then that kind of
felt everything fell apart from there
with that club that guy Howard wanted to
Dan out Dan was a [ __ ] and Dan had lost
himself dan really Dan lost himself and
he wanted to be Hartman I wanted to be
Harmon he wanted to compete with Hartman
Foreman he'd know Hartman the Roger our
carbon eel or manager like he wanted to
rub my he wanted to hang out with
celebrities he wanted to yeah you loved
you know he loved that you know he would
say oh oh you know is that my club his
weekend spade and Sandler and Chris Rock
you know he loves saying those words he
loved going to let him in because the
[ __ ] guy that got fired for saying
chicks ain't funny
anybody Brill he used to that's the only
last club that would hire him because
that was Danny more his way to get on to
let him in oh yeah so grill would get
him let him in tickets and take him out
to dinner and he had lemon for 10 G's
and huh see how that goes
it's [ __ ] amazing how this life works
but he started losing his mind and he
started believing the hype and he was a
great club owner he got a magazine done
with his picture yeah here's that frame
than ever yet in the club those love
wait a fake magazine article like I like
to like a magazine that three college
kids put together with it but like a
cover shot it was he got into the mall
but he's in a Confederate uniform it's
one of those was you get bullied a boy
he really believed the hype he really
wanted to be a player I knew he had
invested off-record and a lot of comics
CDs like you know comics and say put my
name on you see then everything Gribble
Jason Cohen has a producer yeah he was
he was uh he gave me a lot of notes
through the day years I know the [ __ ]
was he at the end of the day
like who the [ __ ] would I touch what
happened to him he went from being a
club manager to being I know everything
about commie look at my club yeah you're
good but stop giving advice stop telling
people they can't drink on stage those
the dumbest [ __ ] loud without getting
[ __ ] up in the green room if you got
your dick sucked be green when we go to
Yona jewy bit you know he was a crime he
was a he was like a double agent
yeah then they come and hang out anyone
a party with where's Joe Rogan where's
Joe Rogan and he sit by Joe and he be
coked up and I can see the steam and Joe
slumping he is getting hotter and hotter
every time he tried to say something his
jaw would be going you know it was just
[ __ ] him beza you know at that time
listen bro I don't know how you guys
feel
let me just tell you guys something this
is how I felt for I'm 52 is how I felt
for 27 years I think when I was 25 one
day I said I feel creepy going on yeah
like I'd see like college kids and I go
you know you feel like that guy that
flunked college and still hanging out
like hello yeah like this [ __ ] but he
made it let you know oh yeah yeah you
said his 20s you feel like that dirty
year old that's lurk it's like when I go
to the weed store and I see the guy with
loads gonna shirt with the ponytail man
55 man there's weight on you like
sitting there going really isn't that
[ __ ] a jitney bus you should be on a
son [ __ ] like Oh ple this is an end to
this trying to be cool [ __ ] there's an
end to it at some point
I flew on a thing today with a 60 year
old that was tatted up and steroid up
your [ __ ] 60 guy then tabouli had a
wig all the wigs are the saddle because
it's 2015 he's still pushing a wig shave
your head like every other [ __ ] gel
and put like a crucifix on your head or
something
what are you Lee like 40 what are you 45
40 26 years old why you like 26 and what
doggers he's a twin see she's only lost
his birth certificate misery he's like
the Cubans they lose every Birsa -
that's why you see here saalu look I
ain't lyin
how high are you
why not like 300 milligrams when I met
Li was 24 4 years old 23 and he never
did an edible look at him now
Wow run the board again bless you
aged 20 years you have but that that eat
that either Vanna that week in Florida
to me was the lat and I thought the rest
of the country was like that I hope I
was in it was uh the summer of 84 and I
was just about to start getting bad with
the blow it was around yeah and I was
dating this chicken a tremendous [ __ ] I
was a lover
I would I would steal panties and jerk
off and I wasn't wizard oh my god she
was [ __ ] tremendous and she sucked
dick and we get coked up together and we
69 in the hotel room is on Fridays and
Saturdays and we used to drink Harvey's
Bristol cream
anybody remember Harvey's Bristol cream
it was like a [ __ ] strong Irish
what's that [ __ ] Bailey's oh yeah it was
like a 90 proof Bailey's that [ __ ] you
up
and it took a broad from point A to
point Z with a half a biscuit and a
couple of lines and me and that chick
would get like I'd saved money to hold
we got like three quaaludes get two
bottles of Harvey's Bristol cream czar
bag Ice Cube's I get I get a hotel room
in Seaside Heights in the wintertime for
like ten bucks I can take it down in an
ad and a set I coke her up and [ __ ]
eat her ass and weed 69 and she'd stop
and do a line of coke and clean her nose
and suck that [ __ ] pipe again those
are days dog those are the [ __ ]
things in your twenty twenties triplet
triplet June 2nd Oh travels that's to
show you one that's a troll like you
want like to show that oh go and see the
underground people shoot heroin be the
snorting blow somebody goes be a nun
should rip do this like it no that's
what people want to see you now but the
injection beam will be blurred
look at this oh v8 look at this over
here eating the biggest sandwich
infected [ __ ] yeah
I want to see what a body's crackle
I want to see bro dog coked-up doing
bombs out of club taking a near beat
from a chick with bad breath at the
bathroom you think if you come to my
place birthday the camera has to follow
you guys let you go back to a house and
she's shooting heroin on she's so big
but you got a crack a nut from the
heroin you put your dick in her mouth
and then she Odie's and you and the
camera crew lead the way down the stairs
you bump into another party I catch the
[ __ ] show right there somebody wants
to see you at a restaurant going on a
roller coaster gives a [ __ ] you in two
seconds show ever
that is listen o matter restaurant
birthright it's August of 84 I have a
psychological wound
yeah I was just starting to digest if my
mother had died when you have a loss
that strong yeah I was in high school I
went to school the next day I'm a
believer and she was still alive in my
head not to deal with it
and finally after four years I had to
deal with it and I'm in a restaurant and
all sudden this guy comes up to me he
goes hey aren't you the norrison he goes
[ __ ] echoes looking for you when
yacón was his friend of the family's I
had one eye that went that I don't when
he to do coke the I would Ravel but he
was [ __ ] I did something from as a
kid one time he had two sons and we also
had a well I did some I did some fun as
a kid one time yeah we all got long
what the [ __ ] we all got along huh you
look like a fairy tale
oh my god
no I gotta solve this story what do you
want to do you think I'm gonna give it
to them cold su8 someone yet goes
looking for you he's got to my mother
died at 79 yeah he came to the wake and
[ __ ] but walk two years we lost contact
with each other when echo was a big-time
drug dealer and 80 and about the time
they killed this is a fucked-up story
that I'm thinking about right now before
my mom died my mom woke me up like a
year before she died and goes hey man I
talked to you about something she goes
you know yet though the son because she
had he had one son that he had twins she
was they killed one of the twins what
like what you talking about she goes
unchecked and him and little deep kid
always was troubled
he od'd in Fort Lee and some house so uh
I'm like that's really sad you know what
are we gonna do it I think we went to
the funeral and what happened we came
home when we got home she came to me my
mom and she's like he wants to talk to
you about something like okay I'm in the
eighth grade seventh grade but my best
friend was that guy right there call
mind the torch pals at war who took that
guy football coach oh yeah
he want no [ __ ] football coach